>> IT'S NEW YORK CITY AND THE
BROADWAY.
BUT WHY NOT GO OFF-BROADWAY,
WHERE THEY'RE NOT AFRAID TO GO
THERE.
INTRODUCING "DIVIDED WE STAND,"
A MUSICAL NOT FRAYED TO GO HEAD
FIRST INTO OUR POLITICAL
CLIMATE.
>> I MEAN NO GOOD.
AMERICAN DREAM?
>> IN A SHOW THAT CAN ONLY BE
DESCRIBED AS DEFINITELY WRITTEN
BY THE ACTORS.
♪ I'M FINALLY ON MY WAY
BEING THE CRADLE OF AMERICA
AND HELLO BROADWAY ♪♪♪
"TIME-OUT" NEW YORK CALLS IT
DANGEROUSLY OVERSIMPLIFIED AND
LITERALLY HELPING NO ONE.
♪ BIRTH CONTROL, BIRTH CONTROL,
IT'S ALL ABOUT CONTROL
I NEED ANOTHER CUP COFFEE ♪♪♪
>> I GUESS THE WORST PART OF THE
PLAY WAS THEIR CONFIDENCE IN IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪ ME TOO, ME TOO, AND YOU AND
YOU AND YOU ♪
IT HAPPENS TO ALL OF US, HOW DO
YOU DO
ME TOO, ME TOO ♪♪♪
>> JESUS CHRIST SAYS "THE NEW
YORK TIMES," AND I DON'T NEED TO
TELL YOU THE CAST WAS ALL WHITE.
>> WE WENT AROUND THE CAST LIST
AND WHAT MADE THEM DIVERSE AND
ONE PERSON SAID, PARENTS
DIVORCED.
>> ALL OF THE VIOLENCE ON THE
FAKE NEWS MEDIA!
LIKE WE READ WIKIPEDIA!
AND TO HELL WITH POLLUTION!
WHAT'S NEXT, REPRINT THE
CONSTITUTION!
>> PLAYBILL.COM WRITES -- I WAS
WONDERING WHY ONE GUY HAD THREE
SEPARATE RAPS AND THEN I
REALIZED HE WAS THE DIRECTOR.
♪ I AM THE STATUE OF LIBERTY
AND THERE'S NO WAY YOU'RE
GETTING INTO ME ♪♪♪
>> UM, I THINK THIS MIGHT DO IT
FOR US.
>> YOU'LL WALK AWAY WONDERING
WHOSE PARENTS PAID FOR THIS.
♪♪♪
♪ SURE WE CAN CAST A BALLOT
AND WE CAN GO TO THE POLLS
BUT WHAT IF WE JUST SANG
WE DON'T HAVE TO DO A THING BUT
SING ♪♪♪
>> I THINK THAT LAST SONG WAS
TELLING US NOT TO VOTE.
>> NOW PLAYING AT THE
MARISKA HARGITAY THEATER.
TICKETS ARE $140?